is there some part of you that regrets
that the chess community and you
included implied that Hans cheated early
on and I think without having evidence
and that kind of thing as we learn now
can stick
right and it kind of divided the just
community in part but like
um I mean I guess I do want to empathize
from from your position can you
empathize with Hans that his reputation
is essentially in part or in whole
destroyed at this point yes I I
absolutely can again I think it comes
down to the specifics of how how it was
handled now as far as I go I was
covering the news and this is what makes
it so difficult for me versus say some
of the other content creators is that I
do in a sense have that inside knowledge
um you know again this is probably this
is also not really public knowledge but
when I went to St Louis to play this
rapid and Blitz tournament before the
single cup happened where magazine Hans
were playing there were people who told
me very specifically that they thought
he was cheating other other players in
the event they even gave me like actual
theories about like things in his shoes
things of this nature yeah so I'm in a
very awkward spot there as well because
I know why I mean I I was like 99 sure
why Magnus dropped out
um it would have come out regardless
though it would have come out no matter
what because Magnus was knocking to back
down on a stance about Hans and others
would have brought it up anyway so
it's it's very tough I think if if you
want to look for for blame I think
probably it would be on chess.com
ultimately because they were the ones
who probably could have nipped all this
in the bud at a much earlier stage and
it wouldn't have gotten to where it got
to because they could have released the
online cheating and that would have I
think yeah I think they could have
released that I think also they could
have probably not let him play after it
happened uh the second time as well
because it seems like it happened like I
I don't I think it was like at least
like four or five different times I
haven't looked very very closely at that
but it wasn't just an isolated incident
and so I think if there is blame for
that it's definitely on trust.com which
should uh stop people from thinking that
like my that I'm in some way influenced
by by yeah are you biased because are
you supported in part by chess.com yes I
am I am okay so so does that affect your
bias no it doesn't I'm actually quite
independent of them one thing that's
that's interesting um to note is that a
lot of people are under the assumption
that when when I do like broadcast of
tournaments or things of this nature
that chess.com is actively helping me
they are not helping me I'm an
independent contractor and so my
opinions are my own and there are no
lists given to me about like cheaters
anything of this nature that has always
been completely separate do they have
compromising video of you that forces
you forces you to uh if you don't follow
the the main narrative that they will
release that video publicly no they
definitely don't
um but yeah I I think I I think when I
look look at it all I feel like if there
is if the if people are looking for for
someone to blame I don't think it's
actually Magnus the end of the day I
think it is it's on chess.com very
squarely for not handling handling it
sooner so you're okay with like Magnus
being silent for long periods of time
well I don't know why Magnus is still
silent because my read of the situation
was that there was some sort of NDA or
there's some information that chess.com
had that it was they they could not
release and so my read of it was Magnus
was essentially saying the same thing
chess.com said where like I can't say
anything about it because of whatever
whatnot but then chess.com releases what
I perceive to be the stuff that they
could not talk about anyway and Magnus
still isn't saying anything so I don't
really understand why Magnus has not
said anything further it could be legal
implications of accusing somebody of
cheating uh over the board that could be
like lawsuits that he just doesn't want
the headaches he just wants to focus on
the game and have fun playing the game
and not get bogged down into lawyers and
all that kind of yeah it's definitely
possible but Magnus could also take the
other route and just say well he cheated
online in 100 games like I'm not going
to play against a cheater that's very
easy to say that's factual it's proven
and that doesn't have to go into the
speculation of over the board so I I
find it a little bit odd that Magnus
hasn't said anything further at the same
time it's also kind of peculiar because
magnus's reputation is also kind of in
in tatters in a sense like a lot of
people are not happy with him for what
he's done uh but still he goes and plays
this tournament in this European Club
Cup Tournament and he's just gaining
like 10 points as though nothing has
happened so I I mean I I don't I don't I
don't really know where magnus's head is
at because like if I was in that
situation and everyone's coming after me
for making such an accusation I don't
think there's any way I'd be I would be
able to play chess anywhere near the
level that Magnus is playing at so the
whole situation is you know it's very
strange yeah I wonder where his mind is
at that he's able to play at that level